hello welcome along to this meeting of
the performance policy
and partnerships committee uh just a
reminder that the live stream is
underway and if you've left your buzzy
vibratory phone sitting on the table
now's a good time to pocket it
um we have an apology from councillor
lewis
with councillor abbott seconded
councillor soper i'll put that all in
favor
aye against carrie
uh two items in public forum first of
all we've got
an update from south alive
uh courtney and beryl and paul
welcome along if you can just make sure
uh whenever you're speaking that it's
into one of the microphones that the
people on the live stream can hear you
as well that'd be great
thank you very much now just introducing
ourselves
i'm beryl wilcox chair of south alive
trust
i'm courtney allison i'm the community
development and operations manager
my name's paul sirenkin i'm the deputy
chair of south alive
so the purpose of our presentation is
just to
update you with the work that south
alive's been currently doing
and coming up we'd really like to
acknowledge
the support that icc have provided
south alive in the past nine years that
we've been operating
and we look forward to continuing the
relationship
so as you'll see our strategic plan
sets out our mission that empowered by
our strengths as a community
we will build a place to live and work
that engenders pride
and inspires us um that was set up in
2012
originally with the support of the
invicago city council
in response to the need of increased
levels of
pride and well-being in our community it
had been identified that that was
extremely poor in south invercargill
we've always followed a cld a
community-led approach
and it has five principles which are
stated up above
it's a very much a grassroots approach
and grassroots means that we're not
there as a board to determine what
happens we are driven by the community
and they and we need to constantly
engage
and complete surveys and research to
ensure
that we are representing the south
invercargill community
in 2018 we entered a partnership with
the department of internal affairs
their community-led development
partnership
and which was extremely fortunate
it's been for a five year going to be
for a five-year term
the only thing is that most of the
funding that comes is targeted towards
projects and outcomes and not
necessarily
operational costs
so in the nine years that we've um been
going we've had
an amazing commitment from a group of
volunteers who've driven all of the work
that we've done
a lot of those fall into our action
teams so they
were developed around people's areas of
interest and strength when we um started
the consultation
back in 2012 and where the community
identified that improvements could
be made so we have a fruit nut team and
they look after
fruit nut trees on eight council parks
in south invercargill
there's more than 80 trees and plus some
very bushes and under plantings
and we get a lot of support from the
local schools too with students from
aurora college and firmwood primary
helping out
and looking after those orchards we have
a housing team who run a series of
seminars on alternative housing topics
like straw bale houses or
transportables and tiny homes and they
also run a number of um
projects like random recognition awards
each year where they give people 50
vouchers and for diax they're
acknowledging the pride and care they've
taken in their street frontages
one of our other action teams is the
beautification team who look after our
community gardens in our park there at
south alive at the pod
and they also look after our zero
rubbish scheme which is where people can
adopt a street and look after it to
clean up the rubbish
we have a pay it forward team which is
our newest team and we've delivered a
lot of food parcels
um that came about around the time of
covert last year
um and we've also got as part of that
pay it forward team a team of knitters
who
um knit products for woolen singlets and
hats and booties for the satellite
hospital
and we've got our events action team who
run a number of events each year we've
got a few signature events like our
annual street party which is usually
around october
our trolley derby and children's day
which is every march
um in some other days like world
kindness day we've got youth gaming
events
three by three basketball markets um
yeah the list goes on
we've historically also had teams for
the dog park
an arts team a youth team and stronger
neighborhoods
and all of this is just driven by the
amazing work of our volunteers
as i mentioned we've got some community
rooms at the pot
there's two community rooms that opened
in april 2019
we have lots of regular groups that use
those spaces like our senior friendship
group that were there this afternoon
our nitwits knitting group we've got an
orchid group
crop swaps art classes for the young and
adult art classes to stand up to we've
also just added in these
two computers into the um
into the pot and those are free for
people to use and free
internet comes on them um so these are
really
a place for people to connect and to
bring people together they've been huge
in reducing isolation and providing
groups and a space for the community
it also generates some revenue for us
through the charges
that we charge so we have some
not-for-profit rates to keep it
accessible for our community
but we um and some business rates which
help us generate revenue
there's also a number of other projects
that we run we've partnered with
nema on some local air quality issues
and so they're putting monitors into
people's homes for three week periods
over winter
and then putting them in a number of
houses just to get our understanding of
the air quality issues
inside homes and then there's also a
number of outdoor monitors that have
gone up
one of our other projects is the south
invical history trail which we're
currently developing
so we've um done a lot of consultation
with the community to find out what
historical points of interest there
might be in south invercargill
and from that this sort of 4.5 kilometer
or sort of one hour walking loop has
been developed
and so we're currently working on
pulling together all of the information
the signage and there will be an app and
things that will be developed
alongside that
food security is an ongoing issue and
that was only exacerbated by
covert 19 so we received some funding
through
the ministry of social development um
for some food security
projects so we've run a number of
workshops on topics like urban gardening
and composting
we've prototyped some planter boxes like
the ones you can see up there
we've been doing orchard tours pruning
and seed saving workshops
so yeah no number of projects in that
space as well
and then that's just a selection of the
other sort of projects and events that
we have
um that we are organizing or have
organized we have free yoga once a month
at the pod we just had our first craft
swap back in may and that was so popular
we'll be holding it again
and this is all quite community-led so
one of our volunteers came in and said
i know you guys do a crop swap but hey
what about a craft swap um
which yeah got huge interest so it's
something we'll do regularly now
we'll world kindness day is something we
celebrate every year
um we ran some resilience rain
resilience workshops
and our driving movies we will be
holding again in september after they
were cancelled due to the weather but
um yeah that's just a selection of some
of the the projects and events that
that we run and something that is on now
and thanks to the support from
the city council through their
well-being fund um
we uh we received some funding for the
school holiday program so we piloted
that in april
and um we're running again bigger and
better these holidays and the subsequent
ones for the rest of the year
so we've had things like yoga for kids
lego free play
um the sports southland sorry active
southland playla
um there for people to free play out in
our community park
and this weekend we've got free comic
book day where we'll be giving away
comic books
and some cooking classes in conjunction
with the pantry
so that's all responding to a lot of the
feedback that we've heard around our
community
around the need for more things for
young people to do in our community
positive things for them to engage in
right here that's a hard act to follow
look i'd like to speak about the pantry
which is our social enterprise it's
about us becoming self-sustainable
not quite there yet but we're working
very hard on it
we run a range of programs around
cooking classes educational items as
well
as well as having obviously items to
purchase and take home i think one of
the important things with our community
is actually you can buy as little as you
want
not necessarily as much as you need okay
um so this has been going since uh 2017
uh we find that
the community that supports it do mainly
because they actually want to be some
part of something bigger
so apart from the good deals it's about
contributing back to the community and
allowing us to support our
organization as i said we've got a lot
of workshops that take place it's also a
central hub which is for
community groups to meet we've got a
scooter club just watch out when they're
on the road
and that turn up and and meet and they
catch up it's pretty much a really good
spot to beat isolation
i think it's really important for our
older generation
that this takes place and we have the
community basketball court which is
right outside
which is also heavily used as well
right i get this page because this is
like a skype sheet for us
if you can look at everything that we do
and
have done and to think that this is
driven from within our community
it's a considerable piece of work
i struggled to work out where to really
start on it because
each portion of that is really important
to the people who have put it up
and the people and the people that
volunteered within it to make them so
successful
you'll see that there's a number of
either regional or national recognitions
for the work itself alive
218 we were the community boards the
national
runner-up and the trustpower awards
we've had regional
awards as well um in 2017
and 16 we were a finalist for
the kiwi bank new zealander of the year
for the community projects
so everything that we do has a volunteer
approach to it
it's what drives us and
this is what we wish to continue
you uh investing in our community
is our last main page here
um we want to talk first of all about
the
social and community benefits and we
talk about the sense of well-being pride
volunteer
difference making volunteer hours making
a difference developing leaders
um it's you can't exactly put a price on
that
it's but it's immeasurable we can
measure
the sense of pride and well-being in
terms of
each year we survey to see how we're
going when we started back in 2005
12 there was only 37
said that they felt proud to live in
south invercargill
at our last survey that we did measuring
centre pride
we jumped to 86 and so we've been
advised once you get over about 85
that you know it's hard to measure after
that so
um plus uh the surveys the feedback
and the volunteer involvement engagement
give us an anecdotal measure of the
benefits
for the social and community aspect the
economic benefits though was one i
wanted to highlight and something not
always so considered
in the last financial year icc
they contributed forty thousand dollars
which they have done
for four five years for part of the
community trust south
loan repayment and that is
finishes in november this year
they've also given us seven thousand
dollars as courtney said for the
well-being fund
i guess in return we pay six and a half
thousand dollars in rates actually
back to the icc um in the last financial
year with other funding
we've received approximately two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars plus
there's more than twenty thousand
volunteer hours that have been
recorded and invested in our south
invicau community
and if you put the minimum wage it's
obviously
approximately four hundred thousand
dollars in value
um we our social
enterprise the pantry that we're hoping
will be
our sustainable long-term future employs
nine staff plus 11 volunteers
mainly part-time staff and south alive
employs
three staff
and once again in um
this year there's been 850 000
of investment generated in the
revitalization of south invercargill
which is a 20-fold return
on your 40 000 investment
i would like to just um point out an
extra item
that we realized in addition since 2017
when invercargill city council loans
started
we've been able to attract 1.3 million
dollars
from outside the region from sources
such as government
and other public areas so not even
looking at
internally here um
if south alive were not here i guess
none of that would happen
and it's all been to the benefit of our
south invercargill community
and i haven't even mentioned the asset
of the building
and the items like the whale tail
sculpture all those sorts of things
we're here to update you thank you for
your support and also ask
if invercargill city council will assist
in our continued investment
with the 125 thousand dollars community
trust south
loan repayment that needs to occur over
the next
five years that's twenty five thousand
dollars a year
and i understand that was probably an
item for a discussion
but we wanted to let you know what we've
done how far we've come
and how we would hope that invercargill
city council would support us
i hope you'll appreciate it's not an
item for discussion today
uh thank you very much for that
comprehensive report and and gentle
reminder of the great deal
of community development work that south
alive
facilitates in the role that the pantry
and the pod are playing in our wider
community
because i know from events that i've
been through there that it's not just
people from south invercargill that take
advantage of it so
we welcome everyone but but um
we're unashamedly there to support south
invercargill
questions councillors
theron thank you very much for your
presentation and taking the time to come
along this afternoon
thank you
don
welcome along mr moyer
councillors you'll know you've also got
a written submission
and the paper's on the table here
thanks uh thanks mr chairman and i
apologize for the um
i do have some extra copies here
incidentally if if they are needed
i apologize for the content of my
submission being considerably less
exciting
than the south alive team who appeared
here before me i i think the work
they've been doing is absolutely
fantastic i had no idea those people are
doing so much down there and
the benefit of the community so here my
subject is
however to me no less important than the
work they're doing
so i hope you don't mind if i if i just
read my submission
so it's on planning restrictions within
the operative district plan
relating to residential subdivision and
development
um i have for some time now been
concerned about the extent to which our
current planning rules are
inhibiting the growth of the city
contributing to the shortage
of new affordable housing and
contributing to global warming
the rules that most concern me are those
imposing minimum allotment sizes for new
residential allotments
and residential development of 400
square metres
it's a discretionary activity to
subdivide allotments or build dwellings
on an area between 400 and 350 square
meters and i've noticed in recent times
that the attitude of council planning
staff in relation to
processing of the discretionary activity
applications
has grown more cumbersome and
restrictive
given that there are other mechanisms
other mechanisms within the district
plan to control matters
such as open space permeable surface
site coverage yards higher structures
and so on why is it necessary to set a
minimum allotment size
that arbitrarily restricts development
historical subdivisions in invercargill
have typically been based on 1012 square
metres
or the quarter acre and through the era
from about 1970 to the early 2000s
one of the most common forms of infill
subdivision and development
involved the subdivision of these
allotments into three parcels
averaging about 337 square meters
so setting a minimum of 400 square
meters only allows two dwellings
on these historical parcels and in my
view that's too restrictive
and it's resulting in residential
development and an unsustainably low
density
so within the residential 1a zone there
is some relief
by way of rules relating to
comprehensive development
on parcels over 2000 square meters
but such sites are scarce and since the
plan became operative there have been
very few such developments
perhaps just one or two so
finally if new zealand is going to meet
its international commitments in respect
respective carbon emissions
our cities must take on a far more
constant condensed form
and invercargill's current planning
rules are preventing that from happening
furthermore if we're going to house our
population
a marked change in philosophy is
required whereby we move from detached
dwellings on individual allotments
to the various forms of apartment living
and so i'm re respectfully asking the
council to have a good look at this
i should point and perhaps perhaps you
already are your staff
already are the productivity commission
of course has some
has encouraged the government to release
the national policy statement on urban
development and that contains a lot of
provisions that that um
that are aimed at the sort of things
that i'm talking about here and so
i i imagine you're you're already doing
some work on this i guess i'm here just
to encourage you
um along those lines as well just from
my perspective
thanks don and don't disagree with the
comments around you know one of the the
solutions to the problem being for
uh councils to look at more apartment
style
living options i guess the thing that
sits in front of us at the moment
is what's being proposed with
uh the removal and replacement of the
resource management act as a whole and
how that could potentially
uh remove district plans
but ultimately what you're suggesting is
that
in the meantime we look at that more
intensive style of housing development
do you think though
it should be restricted to certain parts
of the city or is it something that you
would see
in the suburbs as well no i think i
think that i think you can
quite happily restrict that to parts of
the city you've already got the 1a zone
which probably could do with a bit of
tweaking but not a lot
um and so certainly certainly as a start
within that zone um if you've got a half
acre you can do all sorts of things
it's just extremely hard to get a half
acre together i
quite frankly when the district plan
became operative i thought we'd see a
lot more of those
comprehensive developments and and we
don't seem to be
we're seeing a bit of flexibility so
within that 1a zone
your staff are taking a pretty pragmatic
approach it's not all that difficult
to get back to what i was talking about
which is three
three houses on a quarter acre
that's that's relatively achievable
under current staff attitudes and
current current policies
um but
yeah but but having said that that's
only in that zone and
when i said it's relatively easy it's
actually i should take that back it's
not it's relatively difficult actually
still to achieve
that you've still got to get neighbors
consents um
neighbours have all sorts of reasons for
for refusing to grant extent
refusing to grant their neighbours
consent to do different things on their
properties and their seldomly to do with
serious planning
planning considerations would just be
nice to see the same sort of things that
apply to half acre sites apply to
quarter acre sites basically
you've got to list the criteria there's
a thing from memory around about 13
criteria that apply
if you've got a half an acre and you're
certainly not restricted to
one one per 400 square meters those same
things could quite happily be applied
to to any site and yeah the 1a zone
needs a bit of tweaking um it probably
needs to be broadened out a wee bit
but but by the same token i'm not
advocating that the entire city
you lose some of the advantages of what
i'm talking about if you start
subdividing well outside the city centre
and getting
right down the bottom into south and the
cargo and right up to the top end of
waikiwi
some of the advantages and these higher
densities are in in terms of carbon
footprint are all about transport and
and having your high densities in areas
where people can walk
walk and use public transport that's not
going to apply if you start whacking
rosedale up into
into you know three two or three hundred
square meter sections
so no i'm not necessarily advocating it
for those areas but having said that
in general i still would advocate the
complete removal of any form of minimum
lot size we never used to have it and
there's no ne there is no need for it
i'm
completely unsure why we actually
introduced it
for many many years without it and i'm
not aware that a problem was being
created by its absence
um your other rules your open space
requirements um your
northerly yard requirements those things
they they govern those they govern the
issues in terms of providing
adequate sites for what you're going to
put on them i mean if you're going to
put a tiny house on a section why should
it be the same size
as a four bedroom house why should the
section have to be the same size
so i'm not expecting you to
i probably have talked here about
initiating and i haven't i don't know if
i've talked about initiating scheme
change it's a bit far for that
it's a bit that's a bit more than what
i'm asking for given as you say the
resource management act is about to
probably be replaced by other
legislation and also perhaps just a
handful of
district plans for the whole country so
that'd be a bit pointless but
but a slightly more permissive stance
from your staff would go a long way
you know there's been an awful lot of
periods in this city where we've had an
awful lot of non-conforming subdivisions
and developments approved simply because
that became
that becomes the norm so there are ways
of of subtly
moving in these areas thanks tom
it's open for questions councillors
councillor pottinger thank you cheer
john um with that intensification i mean
i take it 1a is around the cbd yeah
so if you looked at areas like south
city which is
basically self-contained you look at
windsor self-contained
and and other areas where you've got
chemists supermarkets everything
wouldn't you see that that
intensification if you're going to try
and reduce carbon footprint and stop
people driving everywhere
you know that intensification in those
areas means people can walk
sorry yes definitely a valid point here
i shouldn't have just talked about the
cbd you're quite right those clusters of
um around the shopping centre is quite
valid and then obviously work out of
you would you work out how far you go
but that that makes a lot of sense
i mean it's something that the
government's going to drive us into
anyway
but um right
thanks depend on how far evs reach
questions counselors if not
thanks don uh and also thanks for your
forbearance i know you're asked to come
forward to the june meeting and it was a
bit cluttered so thank you very much for
watching
thank you very much
right uh brings us on to the declaration
of interest just a reminder to
councillors that if you do have any uh
conflicts during decision making to
declare them
before the conflict becomes an issue and
that you can update
um the interest register at any stage
counselor crackhead and on that note i'd
just like to
note that tableaus in
active community funding and
crowdtrustee is noted in the
interest register of active scotland
so it will be abstaining from any um
making that particular item thanks
councillor
right that brings us on to the next item
which is the uh youth council so we've
got a couple of members who've come
along this afternoon if you'd like to
pop up into the graham norton not red
chairs
you're quite safe welcome along
last meeting of the youth council was on
wednesday afternoon last week
but since then i think it was on on
saturday you had
the um your event next door
do you want to go through what was what
was involved in that and how that worked
out
uh kia ora i'm evening from the unders
youth council and i go to south and
girls high school
um um kiana i'm nazir from overseas
counselor and i also go to south and
girls high school
so um yeah um last saturday um 10th of
july
um the united nation came down um
u.n youth came down and held a six-hour
regional hui with 20 young people from
invercargill
and southland area and um while i'm at
it i would also like to thank councillor
um sophie for coming along to the event
as well
and we started the day getting to know
each other and
hearing from our guest speaker who were
talking about
the difficulties getting youth
engagement in politics
um short after we were learning about
the te kanga
mori protocols and we thought
like how it would be good to introduce
that to the youth council as well
um in the second part of the day we had
um rugby
group time where we discussed national
issues
um and coming up with solutions for
those and
there was one issue that stuck out to me
which was the topic of homelessness
which if i may um raise a question i
remember about a couple years ago
um with the there was a project with
kiwibuild
announced by the government to build 40
houses in invercargill
and i was just wondering how that
project is coming along since i haven't
heard much about it since
it would be fair to say that kiwibuild
wasn't a raging success so far
elsewhere in the country but i think
there are still plans to to look for
opportunities there have been
uh some smaller developments that have
gone ahead but certainly not at the
the rates that are needed to deal with
homelessness so i think councillor soap
you may well know that the package still
sits on the table and they're looking
for the opportunities the number is
still similar
yeah yeah thank you thanks for your
question
um it was good to hear other people's
perspectives from other schools
um around southland it was good to see
conflicts and debate
and not everyone just agreeing with each
other we had
set morals as a group like not lying
respecting others views and making it a
safe space to share
we had teresa the president of united
nations youth
who was engaging in fun we got a
follow-up email the next day which um
had event details and contact details of
the speakers and web links to
follow up on we had marlon from
elections as our guest speaker who
zoomed in from christchurch
he was the deputy head boy at his former
school and involved in the pegasus
health board
one thing we were surprised it was the
age of youth that the electoral
commission uh asked to engage
with was 18 to 29 there wasn't much
information about how we can make a
difference as a minor in democracy
we would also like to thank you for the
catering and we'd like to thank the
youth council leadership committee and
the ewing youth for putting this day
together
thank you councillors it's open
over to you for questions councillor
soper
thank you mr chair um i don't have a
question i do just want to say i
i went along as an interested observer
and i just wanted to comment that i was
very impressed at the time i was at this
meeting with the maturity and the
breadth of issues that the young people
were discussing
the fact that you were looking locally
nationwide and internationally and what
you were raising
as issues that were worthy of discussion
and the fact that you were prepared to
discuss in quite some depth
and that you were having very mature
discussions between the young people who
are in the room
it gave me a lot of confidence about the
safety
we can feel about the future of air
democracy if we've got young people
prepared to put in that time and energy
on a saturday when you could have been
doing many other things
to be in a room discussing very
important issues
so very complementary of
what what happened that day having been
through that process
and and discussing and debating and in
that atmosphere
how do you expect it might change the
way that you engage
with the youth council
i think that there was like this more
realisation of all the issues
now that we had that day and i think
that it opens for more discussion
in youth council with those issues i
guess my question is does it give you
confidence
to to to raise your voice and and
champion the people
definitely should feel strongly yes
you wish so chair i think one of the key
issues you'll face as young people in
the city is getting a home
and i know it sounds a simple
project but just
countless um
ministers of the parliament and
people from all walks of life you'd
think we'd be able to solve this problem
it what what was some of the thoughts
around that
i'm sorry can you um repeat your we're
looking at ways of becoming home buyers
or other initiatives like home
builders or sweat equity i think it's
called
if the answer was no that's fine
have a ponder of it and and if we come
up with an answer through youth council
we can take it back to its worship yeah
cool any other questions counsellors
counselor cricket you after uh happy to
move the recommendation
indeed secondary to second thank you
councillors oprah put that all in favor
all right
against carried thank you very much for
your time on saturday and and going
along to
to be a part of the event and for taking
time out and you know having to leave
school early to get along here and
present to us this afternoon thank you
very much
thank school oh you holidays
i still thank you you'll be doing
anything or no you can
councillors that brings us on to the
minutes of performance policy and
partnerships from
tuesday the 8th of june does somebody
want to move their true and correct
councillor sopa seconded councillor
amundsen
any matters arising
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
aye
against carried
we've got the minutes of the
extraordinary uh meeting
on june 30th i'll move councillor abbott
seconded
councillor any matters arising
if not i've put the motion all in favor
all right against
carried
right potential submissions on the
legislation
uh relating to environmental reforms
which kind of follows on from
what we were hinting at with mr moyer
before
welcome along liz do you want to take us
through the paper
kia ora um my report is really a heads
up
um as you may be aware there's a reform
um
proposed by the current government
to wipe out what we have now in the
resource management act and replace it
with three other pieces of legislation
the process involved in bringing this
piece of legislation these other three
pieces of legislation
into into effect is going to be quite
fast
um and it's not going to give us a lot
of time
or opportunity to have input into it in
2020 there was a randison report
released which um gave a critique
of the resource management system as it
is now and gave some ideas going forward
and the government is taking that report
as a as
pretty much the consultation or the
background to the new piece of
legislation coming forward
this report has been brought to you just
to
advise you that there is this reform
going ahead and that there is a
submission process
that council may want to to be involved
in
however due to the really tight time
frames and giving that
those submission processes there may not
be an opportunity for us to workshop or
bring it to council for
for a resolution or discussion um and so
we are hoping to to make a submission
on behalf of icc um we've got the the
most recent piece of legislation that's
come out to us in term form of an
exposure draft
is the natural and built environment act
we've got until the
start of august to make a submission on
that so we've only got two more weeks
to submit just to let you know staff are
working with
the other southern councils in this
space
and as we're also working with the
councils from around otago as well
so like this morning we had a two-hour
zoo meeting with the otago south and
regional managers um to see if there
were any ways that we can
can accumulate work together and come up
with a submission that covers both
that doesn't necessarily mean that we
wouldn't put our own submission and we
didn't
agree with what the other councils
wanted to see
thanks liz and it's good to hear that
there's a regional approach being
being taken um i guess i can appreciate
that the short turnaround means that
you're you're looking for for some
license to be able to to be nimble
but i think because we're looking at
doing that uh collaboratively with the
other councils i take a bit of
confidence in that
counsellors it's open for questions or
comments counselor partner
thank you chair um liz can you just give
us
just a couple of quick sentences the
guts of what the natural
and built environments build sort of
contains that
that would worry us right
so currently in new zealand we've got
over over a hundred
um plans for the regional level and a
district council level
um the new legislation would like to
accumulate all of those
plans so the regional plans and the
district plans down into one plan per
region so there would be 14 plans
so before that can be
created the natural built act is
proposing that there'll be a national
planning framework so it
at a central government high-level state
um they will guide us as to what the
outcomes are that we should have in our
district plans
there will be another piece of
legislation which is a strategic
planning act
which will come out at the same time as
um the natural and
built environment act and that will ask
us to have a regional spatial plan
um and from that we will build that into
a
natural and built environments plan
which is essentially what our
what a district plan is and what the
regional plans are
thank you councillor cracker oh thank
you
um with the implementation of regional
plans uh and did we stand to lose any
local autonomy on how we allocate
resource
yes um so the whole planning system will
be
completely changed from what we know it
is now um
and there will be committees that will
sit outside
the council so each local authority will
have
one person nominated to sit on that
committee who will make the policy
um as well as the tango definitely the
region
so um just for argument's sake if we
were to
decide um that we want expansion in
particular area of the city
it would be not only up to us but our
regional
counterparts to agree that that is
actually
of benefit to the city i see that as a
risk because how is that
up to the south district council or to
decide what we
do with our city boundaries
yeah so essentially at the
regional spatial plan stage that would
be the time that we would have input
into
where our growth areas or um maybe
debates will happen then in terms of
where industrial development should be
and
all of those sorts of things so um
potentially fraught
quite a different approach to what we
have now absolutely
it works two ways though i'm sure that
rural counterparts are probably feeling
similarly nervous
counselor sopa then councillor arnold
thanks mr chair um
i'm certainly very supportive of putting
in
the submission and where possible making
it
a regional view although there's
obviously some points where there might
be slightly different views
um in the region um but i do just want
to make it clear this is an
exposure draft which means the
legislation hasn't yet been
formally introduced into parliament
when it is introduced there will be a
normal select committee process
which includes the calling of
submissions so i just for
for the sake of the public i just wanted
to make it very clear
this is not the only chance we will have
to
put forward the council's views on this
particular issue yep that's right um at
the moment the exposure draft is only a
high level there's a whole lot of place
keepers within the document that we've
got yet
um that we don't have detail on that
will come they're hoping early next year
we will have
the bill that will go to um go for the
further
formal submission process so through you
mr chair
i just wanted to emphasize that this is
our opportunity
to make our submission contribute to the
bill
being a well-written bill
councillor arnold um
um being that we won't have a time to
workshop or
um have any views at all on to
as to what forming the submissions will
take do you have any idea a rough idea
what things that you'll be looking to
add into the submissions
because obviously the submission will be
to give them
things that we would like as a region
down the airways to give you any ideas
just tell us what you're thinking of we
haven't really formulated a view as of
yet and we've
only really been given it a couple of
weeks ago to sit down and work out the
detail
um discussions at this morning with the
regional
level was just making sure the nuts and
bolts that the wording is consistent
through
um it talks about limit setting outcome
setting
um and just making sure that the process
actually works
um there's some matters that can be
dealt with through the national planning
framework
um and some matters that aren't required
to be in that national planning
framework and we need to make sure
that things like um high-value soils
and the competing interests with that
and
the demands for urban growth are dealt
with appropriately so it's
it's really i haven't we haven't
formulated a
specific level yet but um we just want
to make sure that the built
environment is given as much um input
as the natural environment at the moment
it seems to be quite focused on
air and water and the natural world
if i may um i think it's like it's
probably fair to say that
uh the key message in our submission
will be there's insufficient detail
in which to matter right
wouldn't be the first time what time
i've made that sort of submission lately
but
any other questions counsellors
still recommendations there the reports
received and endorse the approach the
council officers be able to prepare in
larger submissions i'm happy to move
there to see a secondary
sopa put that all in favor
against caring
michael come on up
update on earthquake prone buildings
good afternoon um i'll briefly summarize
the work to date before taking any
questions if you
if you'd like now following an amendment
to the building act in 2017
the council here set about public
consultation process in order to
identify priority
priority building areas within our
district these are areas of sufficient
vehicular
or pedestrian traffic or of strategic
importance
this was completed in 2018 and result in
the priority areas shown at the
rear of your the rear of your report
being identified
we then carried out inspections on 420
buildings in that area
and following that 211 buildings were
identified as potentially earthquake
prone
through 2018 and 2019 owners were then
written to requesting
they provide engineering assessments
within 12 months
due to the covert lockdown last year a
one-off extension of 12 months was
provided to these owners
we're now at the end of this extension
period and we've moved into reviewing
engineering assessments
and making decisions on whether
buildings are earthquake prone
the numbers in the summary table at the
end of the report show that
for the year to date we've issued 93
earth rate brain building notices
there are two types of notices i'll get
jonathan to
to hold these up so the
one on the left there they aren't with
the orange border that's for buildings
with a zero to twenty percent rating
it's got the distinct orange border
around it
the other one we put out is for
buildings between 20 and 34
so it's just plain black and white all
over
we're going to be seeing these in the
city going forward building owners are
required to fix these in prominent
locations on the front of their building
some buildings require multiple multiple
sites with their multiple entry points
the intent behind these is that building
building users
know what they're walking into before
they go in
in addition to that the buildings are
also identified in the mb online
earthquake prime building register
now we're receiving calls from building
owners and likewise tenants who've
suddenly realized they're in an
earthquake prime building it's fair to
say
it's not being well received
unfortunately there's little
to do little way around this with it
being a legislative requirement
put on us by central government the
remaining priority buildings
relate to emergency use medical centers
and education buildings
they're being worked on separately with
relevant agencies or ministries
once we've finished the priority
buildings our attention then switches to
the non-priority buildings around the
city
there looks to be approximately 2000
properties which we have to investigate
going forward thank you very much
thanks for the good news michael
councillor partner thank you
cheer i'm right just uh i'm going to
pick
a random earthquake-prone building out
of the blue
say the old hotel in front of the bluff
oysters
um what's the future with that of the
people being
served an earthquake notice so the
options that
i mean it's a tough one
it is a tough one that seems to be a
common theme i'm hearing
with other building center of similar
age
um from the day they're actually the
earthquake building notice for those
priority buildings which goal street
bluff is
a priority area they've got 12 and a
half years
to seismically upgrade their building
or knock it down or knock it down i'm
not sure the heritage issues with that
one rick what happens with the heritage
then when you're in a
stalemate um we haven't got to that
point yet
i can probably speak to that a little
bit more um yeah just
clarification you're specifically
talking about the club hotel it's the
yeah the one
um yes so uh it's yet to be determined
how
that will actually fall out the
legislation was changed in 2017
um we're we're in the early stages of
the implementation
um under the rma there is no um
our absolute requirement for stewardship
on a building to the point that it has
to be retained
beyond all date so that has to be taken
into account
with that specific building we are
actually in discussion with the owners
about what the next steps will be for
them
okay and those discussions would be
available to people in the same position
yeah exactly thank you just just further
if they are a heritage one category one
or two here to new zealand building
they can apply for a 10-year extension
to the twelve and a half year period
they can only do that after they've
received the notice and that but they
can they do that ongoing or is it just a
one-off it's a one-off one
yeah going through the priority
buildings
and heritage buildings the next
cab off the rank where council-owned
buildings if they've
all been inspected as the stage the ones
that reside in their priority area
yes they've been part of this and have
the reports been received back to
council
on all them
the report's been come from your
division back to council
ah i'm not aware of that name that'll be
with paul horner
we've received the reports in line with
the time frame certainly
yeah the building services department
have received the are you asking if
they've come
to council yeah through the ceo or the
mayor
news office we can follow up for you and
if that's not the case we can certainly
enjoy
they will have gone to the office of the
ce if there was
a resounding issue um but we
will follow up and just check on that
for you
there's a lot of interest out there with
the museum
that one's obviously closed i know it is
but there's
a lot of people still asking uh has the
report been
inspections been done and completed and
reports received so i'm just asking that
question
on behalf of a number of ratepayers
right you didn't specify the museum
you asked about council buildings
which of course the museum is now but we
had a
report an intrusive report done and
council's in possession of it
was there something else you were after
i just went up onto the
an update councillor clark yeah just as
a
follow-on from that um they might be
able to give me some help with this
i don't understand why the museum is
actually a priority area
when you look at the cla class one
criteria that's in the
thing it talks about high traffic and uh
and the ability of um
emergency services to use the roads and
and it seems odd on the map that we put
a little pink
boundary around the museum yet it sits
on a road that has little
or no traffic and only minimal foot
traffic at any one point of time
so i was interested in why that's class
one because it was class two
or not priority um the time frames the
result would be 25 years not 12 and a
half
the other issue is whether we've
actually done that yet given that
it's in the thing i think that's what my
colleague council was asking about
i thought it was interesting was the uh
with the analogy of the club hotel
in uh bluff life community have tried
already all the trust that owns it
has tried already to get a consent to uh
to flatten the building
um the response from the heritage people
was that they were okay with that
and they were declined on the grounds
that they hadn't made an economic case
for
expanding the oyster vessel um so
leading on from council pond you're
saying i thought that was interesting as
well that um
is that do we have a uh does an owner
like that have
a mandate now that they've been
designated to push for a consent
deliverable risk so interested in both
those views
one the museum and one about the club
hotel sure
all i can say on the museum so that was
put out for public consultation and then
adopted by council in 2018 was the
council decision to include the museum
sure um i might get jonathan to comment
on the resource consent side
uh all i can really say is that we're
still stepping through it with the
building owners
the earthquake prone legislation you're
talking about 12 and a half years and
there's
there's a difference between immediately
dangerous and an earthquake growing so
we need to bear in mind as well yep just
just going back to the
museum again then um so
while we might have consulted about the
priority areas the act does have
the definition of class one and class
two that's my understanding
and so if we've got that wrong if we
designated priority or the community
consultation
designated in such a way that it's
priority or class one where in fact the
act
determines it somewhere else then surely
the act would apply wouldn't it
um it's not so much class one or two
that's that's more related to the
heritage the
the discretion of the council is if it's
sufficient vehicle or pedestrian traffic
i'm
sure we can only assume that council
considers it enough people
at the museum to warrant it being a risk
thank you councillor cricket oh thank
you councillor i just wanted to
give a little bit of uh context to why
council had included the museum and
you'll also notice on that map there
that there's the
water tower and the water utilities
included in that as well is that
this council and that time last term um
wanted to lead by example and make sure
that if we were
uh having those zonings where we were
ensuring that we were going to be
you know issuing earthquake prone
notices that council wanted to be
leading from the front and ensure that
we
too were putting those notices on our
buildings and making sure that we were
holding ourselves accountable to the
legislation so
um that's why they were included we
didn't want to be seen to be
you know one standard for the public and
another standard for
ourselves um i hope that gives you a bit
of context on that
counselor thanks mr chair i just want to
concur
exactly with councillor councillor um
crackit's
memory of the decision there it was very
much to do with
us being seen as actually leading by
example and
not being open to accusations that we
had deliberately
favored our own buildings when we were
drawing a line
around a large part of the inner city
thank you and further questions or
comments
not the report is intended as an update
and thank you very much for that there
are three recommendations if somebody
wants to move you're right counselor
have you torn something i thought
it stopped rip the bandage off
yes absolutely thank you for that i'll
move secondary
kelsey rather than jack the ripper
i'll put that all in favor against
carrie thank you very much for that
thanks councillors that brings us to uh
mr morris's report
on the manafeno appointed roles
um just before we go into this i will
go around each of the counselors um to
canvas your opinions on it but i'm going
to um
make use of standing orders so that's
really the the speak once
so when you've got an opinion you want
to share you have one opportunity to do
it
you can ask additional questions of
clarification
um but those are legitimate questions
not cleverly
couched comments if you're all
comfortable with that
mr morris thank you i think you had
tenukato
councillors good afternoon um chair your
worship
counsellors this is the manifesto report
before i go through
uh my report there are just uh
a handful of small changes i need to
make to the recommendations
just changing one word
and adding a new number five and
renumbering current number five to
number six
this is just for clarity
so the first change is and 2.1
i've currently got a points i would like
to change that to create
yeah so um establish
no let's go for establish i think that
was that's a better word
um and then so this is 2.1 in my
recommendations
and then insert in a new number five
which is to resolve to appoint the
persons to the roles
on 24 august 2021 which is the next
council meeting
not the first council meeting in august
so could you resolve to appoint the
persons
to the roles
on on 24 august
2021
and then number five becomes number six
so the aim with that was just to provide
that clarity that council was still yet
to formally appoint the persons into the
roles
rather than at not being as specific as
it could have been so i do apologize for
that all right
so without further ado into my report
you'll recall on the 11th of may uh it
was determined not to proceed with a
maori award for
the city at the october 2022 elections
at that time following feedback from
both manufa
and the wider community a report was
called for on
the establishment of roles for
manafenoua
this is that report and you'll notice
obviously from the recommendations that
the staff recommendation is that these
roles are
created and are established
as to be operative from september 2021
so the appointments will need to be made
on 24
august which is the council meeting
before september
the roles would be for one person each
from both of the roonaka who
are in our city district so hope i and
arawa
and i will notice a cave and a note that
dunedin city council recently adopted a
similar measure
for the manufenua seats last month
as part of our ongoing obligation to all
of maori i am recommending that we also
engage with matawaka
to ensure that their voices continue to
be heard
i notice a number of councils have uh
arrangements between mana work with
manafenoua and matawaka to ensure that
there is an adequate representation of
all mighty
and this is the start of that process
with mata waka
i think it is an important step to take
to engage appropriately with
all of maori but importantly we need
to engage firstly with amanafinoa
and there is the uh point in there that
it is recommended that these roles be
renumerated by way of an honorarium
that has not yet been the level of that
has not yet been determined the reason
for that is we need to work with
manofenua to establish the scope of the
roles which
if they're established today we will
have an idea
and that can come back by way of a
report to the cheers
committee once that work has been
finalized
so i'm aware that there will be a number
of questions that we want to be asked so
i don't intend to take any more time
going through my report
but i am as always happy to answer
questions thanks michael can i just ask
a question of clarification around
process whilst we're receiving the
report
the recommendations from this meeting
today
go forward to full council for adoption
only for council can resolve to
appoint roles to the committees thank
you
okay councillors if we start with
questions first and then we'll we'll get
into
uh expression of opinion shortly after
councillor abbott then councillor clark
yeah michael i just wondered why it was
going back to the chairman's committee
about the remuneration and not coming
back to this committee
uh at the moment my view is the chairs
committee is an appropriate place
because
that's where the chairs will be it's a
useful venue that's my recommendation
happy to have council resolve that it
comes back to full council to determine
um this committee
yeah i'm comfortable by the way
thanks councillor clark yeah through
your chair um
i'd like to uh move an amendment to the
cluster on
on recommendations too we haven't got
anything for you to amend yet
i'm just trying to deal with questions
at the moment
but by amend no one has put the
recommendations
so therefore it is impossible to amend
can we just deal with questions first
and then we'll we'll get to the
recommendations
do you have some some questions what do
you want to hold on
i've got a series of them if you want to
work right through the form that's fine
or the floor is yours thank you
michael um
just some uh issues around the report
that aren't clear to me
you've said there that in recommendation
four that we've yet to adopt that
we would consult with mata walker and
recommendation for on the role of marry
within the local government act
how do you perceive that we'll do that
with the two
appointed roles being um only
so the pointed roles are for manafenoua
because they are who
the treaty relationship is with matawaka
are included and they all have maori
framework within the local government
act
which is why it's important to also
engage with them to make sure that they
have an appropriate mechanism to engage
with
council however when we consider the
treaty of waitangi and its obligations
that is with the manifenoa of this land
which
is the runaka of nato
so you're suggesting that that uh mata
waka's voice will need to be through
monophenol
and away yeah yes okay that's why not
exclusively
sure i noticed that we you've
recommended in here that we have two
room nanga
appointees one from each running one
from our
one from wahoo um i don't understand why
uh this isn't this representation isn't
a tribal one so where naidah
represents to present us with a
representative as opposed to having one
per minute because if you consider the
um if you consider ngati peroan and the
gizman district council they've got 71
rise now it would never be suggested you
have 71 people on the committee
so i don't know why we have two when we
actually should only
in my view have one so i'd like some
understanding about why we've
landed with two as opposed to one
we've gone with uh two on this case
because we have two
the two who are both representing
different areas
they have different interests sometimes
they could be competing interests
each council is free to make its own
decision on how it
best involves manafenoua
i acknowledge your point that in areas
in the north island i come from one
number two
there are many mirai in the manual too
including different
ewing and ngati rokawa for example
but in this council we have turinaka who
both sit within our district boundaries
they are able to both be represented at
this council table they both have a
voice that needs to
be heard um
if the runaka felt they could be
represented by one person
they would tell us and we will promote
that on their behalf
of course the council can determine to
have
one representative uh that is an option
available to the council but the staff
recommendation is that we have torunanga
like dunedin city it seems logical to
involve both of them
within decisions in these committees
yeah i could i could understand that but
um one of the recommendations in
recommendation two
is that we're offering our mirai
a representative on the bluff community
board so that would seem to me
to signal their their voices already
being heard through that mechanism
why do they then get another seat or
another voice
at a committee level as well given that
the cliff
bluff community board reports back to us
so the bluff community board is only an
advisory role it's not able to be a
voting role
and for that reason they had felt that
they do not
need to be at the committee table where
their votes will
count the bluff community board
has a limited number of delegations
compared to both of these committees and
it's important to have
a district that's represented both of
its furunaka
uh not excluding bluff or the arab
boundaries just a couple of more
questions
um i've heard today that you say that um
dunedin have
adopted a uh two representatives
um do you know what honorariums are
being paid to those people
that hasn't been determined yet for my
understanding that we will be in contact
with dunedin city to engage with them on
what they are doing
in your view without preempting what
council may decide is it reasonable to
accept that
if we wanted a new voice on our
committees they'd be paid the same as a
councillor
oh um i don't have a personal view on
what they could be
paid yep that's fine and the very last
issue for me i guess is the one of
our significant engagement policy would
seem to me reading that policy
that this is a significant shift in our
democracy
to include these ewe um appointees
i can't see the rationale in the paper
where you say
well you've got to see us there is no
need to consult with the public on this
matter
so the rationale behind that was that
this
follows on from the maori ward
discussion that we had
consulted as part of the maori ward
discussion while i acknowledge
immediately that maddie ward and
manafinoa seats
are different issues they were linked
sufficiently
for that level of engagement that we
felt comfortable not to proceed to full
public engagement
again that is the decision that if this
council chooses to
do public engagement
then that will be the resolution and we
will i will work with rhiannon and her
team to ensure that public engagement
takes place and it is heard so
let me just test that line of logic just
a little bit
so at the time we went to consultation
over the maori ward
to the public or where the public
advised that a consequence of
that consultation may be that
subsequently
we might install uh two appointed roles
without public consultation because it
seems to me we only went to the public
on the maori ward issue
so they were linked at the time of the
discussions with the public
that the maori award was discussed
that when we were talking with the
public
that there were other options to ensure
maori voices at council
being the manifesto seats um
but i acknowledge your point that at the
time we went to consultation it was on
the maori ward question it was
not specifically on the monofinal roles
but they were linked sufficiently for it
to be considered that it was appropriate
to be able to proceed without full and
further public consultation on this
issue
one final question and that that's the
membership of
on committees for people who are not
elected
uh by way of the norm election process
do the people that are committed to
these appointments are they covered by
the local government act
so fragments are they subject to codes
of conduct
the provisions of public exclusive
meetings police screening
as they are appointed to this committee
and the answer is yes okay thank you
all right have you thank you further
questions
councillor amundsen mine wasn't really a
question it was a
comment to support what michael was
saying i could make the same thing and
that i heard the
consultation and the three venues that i
was at touch on the matawaka seats
uh other questions at this point before
we
do a round table
right if there are none uh then we first
need
something to debate so i'm going to
uh move the two recommendations
uh as amended so that's recommendation
one received the
report and recommendation to recommend
that council establish two roles one for
each renaka on the performance policy
and partnerships committee
and the infrastructural services
committee with full voting rights
offices offers an advisory role to the
bluff community board
for tirunai or aorua resolves to consult
with tagatfenua on
persons to be appointed to the roles and
implementation issues
resolves to consult with matawaka on the
creation of manafenuwa appointed roles
and the role of almighty within the
local government that 2002
framework resolved to appoint the
persons to the roles on 24
august 2021 resolved to commence the
roles from
september 2021 there's epic ii
thank you it now opens it uh for
discussion
councillor clark sure um i'd like to
move a uh
amendment to the um clustering two one
three two six
replace it with that this paper should
be left on the table without any
decisions
for the incoming council on october 2022
to consider an actopol
so that is a proposed amendment to uh
recommendation too sure is there a
second debt for that clarify
you're saying leave it till the next
term
that is what i heard concrete like say
sorry this paper be left on the table
without any decisions for the incoming
council in october
2022 which is the next election to
consider
an act upon
so that's proposed amendment that needs
a secondary
the lack of a second of the amendment
lapses which brings us back to
councillor kit
yes i've seen that
very well there's nothing like just
after the gate shuts
however i'll not deny you the
opportunity
so on the amendment councillor uh
councillor clark you have the
right to speak uh thank you chad um
this recommendation aligns with option
three that's in the
paper that's been presented to us today
which gave us an option to consider an
information
implementation date at the next election
my recommendation goes further than that
and and suggests that we shouldn't make
a decision today that we should wait and
consider other things as
matters that are before us that we
haven't considered so support for the
recommendation that i've just put
is that there are a raft of issues
within the paper that need further
analysis
beyond that the approval of manufacturer
roles
does in my view not aligned with hip hop
the paper being developed or has been
developed by the government
the direction of naitahi leadership in
recent times the two
2010 human rights commission report
nor the 2021 local government
reform panel mandate
as i said previously further given that
this approval
has a significance to our committee is
unacceptable to me
that we do not open the discussion for
public consultation
in relation to a period plan that's a
recent
there's been recent national debate over
this plan which was commissioned by the
labour government
the plan is a 20-year plan to afford
rangatiratanga a framework
to the tribes i understand that the
38-page report has not yet been
formally adopted by cabinet but there is
no doubt that the recent government
activity
has already embedded the core principles
of co-design
co-governance self-determination of all
services
that in the future will impact on ewe
rangatiratanga and the plan is very much
about erie having ownership
self-determination co-governance and
control of a wide range of crown
activities that impact on ewe
i see this as a very positive and
important development
the co-design and co-governance
principle is evidenced by dia
suggesting to naitahu that equal
stakeholder
group that we now have in the three
waters group
that we've been considering so the two
stakeholder groups with equal say
are the 28 councils on one side and
naitahu on the other
you can also see similar criteria being
embedded in recent
developments around the regional
strategic partnership fund
which is a 200 million fund that follows
the provincial growth fund
and also the recent police rock program
which is to build resilience around
organized crime
the human rights commission report that
came out in 2010 had
some interesting implications for the
government the report reflected on maori
representation and local government it
stated local government was very
inconsistent
and there was a reluctance to address
these issues including from central
government
one of the key recommendations back 11
years ago was there need to be further
national
discussion on improved provisions for
maori representation
prior to he he was just recently come to
the fore
i'm not aware of any national discussion
around this issue
on the issue of direction of naitah
leadership i think there are
several points to consider naitahu
leadership in christchurch was very
clear recently
that he people is coming and will
determine a different approach
to the well-being to their well-being
their rangatiratanga
their control of their own futures to
quote teemari poe who was at the meeting
with mares
this is coming you need to suck it up it
is going to wash over all of you
and while that was intimidating for some
people i thought it was a good statement
by the tribe
that the old status quo way of dealing
with things was no longer
fit for purpose the guiding principles
of the hippie power
now overarched the local government
reform process
interesting to note that what we're
attempting to do is going in the
opposite direction from what naitah
leadership
are wanting to go and i'll deserve that
in two areas
the southam mural forum which is a high
level
significant leadership forum in southam
involves the four mayors
recently of naitahu one position for
each rounder
with voting rights on our structure so
that gave
four more votes back into a forum that
only had them
four mayors and four deputy mayors naita
who rejected that offer
and on the issue of the electoral maori
awards naito had the chance for a maori
ward at the next elections
and turned that down as well so both
these rejections for
in my view reflect for me that um naitah
is no longer seeking to be a minority
role
on any group and to me that would
include this council
under partnership and consultation
principles of the past
because those status quo things have not
delivered
an increased well-being for the tribe
and its members
they are now seeking rangatira
retirement principles as defined in the
1998
nitai settlement act by way of co-design
and co-governance
and a bicultural approach that avoids
separatism
having said that under there is
considerable separatism
in the outcomes of the 2020 sorry of the
20-year period plan
and so um from my perspective the draft
report and final reports that are coming
from the local government
reform panel will be available for us at
the 2022 election
it would seem to be appropriate to wait
to identify what local government will
look like
we may not be here post the next
elections we could be in
a combined council with other councils
and what direction central government
is giving to maori representation rather
than embedding a monophenol role now
only to possibly change it in late 2022
or in 2023 without knowing what central
government or naita
wish from this hippois plan
and what the local government reform
will guide us on
it is my view it's inappropriate to
approve these monophenol roles
until we know what is expected of us and
other councils
thank you thank you councillor clark
just so
councillors are clear what we are
speaking on now is councillor clark's
proposed amendment
that the items sit on the table until
the next trianium
other speakers for or against counselor
sopa
and then his worship
thank you mr chair and speaking against
the amendment i want to start by saying
people can find a million reasons
for putting off or delaying to tomorrow
what should be done today look at some
of the issues through history which came
down to the same sort of arguments
councillor clark has just been
presenting
the arguments against the abolition of
slavery
some of those arguments came down to
slaves are children who won't be able to
manage by themselves so let's leave it
for another century or two
look at the arguments against the
extension of both of the vote to woman
which came down largely to women do not
have the intelligence to handle the vote
let's leave it for another generation or
two until they are educated
until men have delivered them the
ability to reason to the extent that
they can exercise
a vote responsibly let's bring it to the
modern
setting 1981 arguments
against the
protests at the spring box which came
down largely to let's keep politics out
of sport
and let's have white teams because we've
always had them and we
we want to have a rugby game 2007
the argument that it was not the right
time to repeal
section 59 of the crimes act and to
address the issue
of family violence in this nation
a lot of those issues come down to
arguments from people who
are talking from the view of fear of
change
a desire to have the state safe status
quo that they have
already had the safe and unchanging
status quo that they have had for all
their lives and which they would like to
continue
but sometimes just sometimes
history catches up with you
and it becomes the right time to do the
right
thing the
proposal from councillor clark to amend
comes down to a misrepresentation of
hapuapua
i am not going to do a great deal of
speaking on that because i think that
misrepresentation can be researched by
anyone
it is not accepted government policy it
was a discussion
paper it also comes down to a
misrepresentation of the views of
naitahu leadership
and i would like to point out that no
one at this table can speak for the
naitahu leadership
as i said in speaking against this
amendment
sometimes history catches up with us
it's time the right time to do the right
thing
this for me is one of those times
it's time that we actually acknowledge
that we are a bicultural nation
nothing that counselor clerk has put
forward and speaking to his amendment
seemed to me to acknowledge that
we are a bicultural nation whose
indigenous peoples
were promised unique rights
through a treaty partnership and we
haven't
got there yet this council has the
chance to die
with the substantive motions
to actually start that delivery to
actually say
that we do wish
cultural partners to be at the same
table
in a meaningful way i'm not going to
delay any further but i do want to
finish with this
matero
with your food basket and my food basket
people will thrive i will be voting
against this amendment
i will be voting for council to take the
brave step
that it is time and the right time
to deliver partnership not just
the occasional poultry or the occasional
ability to sing a waiata but an actual
commitment to the partnership
that will take this nation and our
peoples forward
thank you your worship
yes well i find myself in an unusual
situation
counsellor that's so bad because i agree
with
what you're saying i feel the time
that we've put off issues and just
kicked for touches
the colloquial version of it just can't
go on
we've got to at some stage
face up to our obligations that our
colonial powers made with the queen
or the crown and there's been
countless books now and literature
claudia orange was a classic case
but many writers and artists have turned
towards looking at that vital part of
our community
the situation
of trying to lock out
uh some of the tangata fenua
is not um an option to my
mind we've got to face up
to this and we've got to do it as
quickly as we can
and people have adjusted we've
i marched against the treaty of waitangi
saying it was a fraud
uh but it was um
oh sorry there's some someone bungee
jumping outside the window
as long as they come back up yes that's
what i thought
um see
uh it isn't an unusual issue
i went to matariki over the weekend
two weekends ago and
it was packed and people loved the
thought they were got involved in
actually being part of an event that
celebrates the relationship we have
i know it's had faults but
it hasn't been broken
and i think this is our up and an
excellent opportunity to say let's heal
the wounds of the past
let's give congratulations to
all parties i mean you look at the role
of te fiti in our
country's history they were
gandhi like pacifists who
brought a lot of peace and inspiration
when they could have
done the opposite um
and it's not if you some of the
um councillor sopa referred to
saying that it was
time i think that
that was a critical period
in our history and
i was only elected for
uh six years on the auckland regional
council
and we had two representatives mrs
minhinik and another who
[Music]
i can't remember now but they were two
ladies very respect well respected
and they felt that
it shouldn't be made of fuss off it
should just be a natural
thing that they want to be represented
on the table
and paid because often artists and
activists don't get paid
and they wanted to be the voice for
auckland
city with that time of 1.4 million
people and there was no objection
no controversy no fuss
and it passed through and
set to framework for
[Music]
a dynamic relationship not one that
you're dragged into but one that you
voluntarily
want to be part of
[Music]
so that's my brief i
i hope we can work our way through this
in the best manner possible i'm
not going into all the details that my
lunar colleague
that it has certainly an issue
that i feel proud to be part of
thank you thank you your worship
councillor abbott
yes i thank you for that um we're a
diverse range of people around this
table and in
various ages so my perspective from a
slightly older person
is a few notes that i made up and i
admit i vexed over this
because in my era we were brought up to
believe that everybody had potential for
development
and indeed success
but and it also said that in those days
democracy allowed anybody any culture
or even representation and
sadly i don't see those beliefs come to
fore anymore in
the pre-generation i see
problems and what's the word i'm looking
for
my difficulties towards religion sexual
orientation
all those sort of representations
cultures
and i've seen prejudice to racists
and individuals that i've known woman
lbgt etc
and cultures so i'm saying that
uh why ivex says that i believe that
all races and cultures should be
represented
and i'm going to support the original
nation because i think
like leslie sofa this is a small step
to the right action
now just a point of order here just
seeking clarification of where we are
in regards to talking about the
amendment which is purely
about deferring a decision-making
process as opposed
to the actual substantive item which
we've yet to debate thank you
so here's the answer we've just had
three speakers speaking against the
amendment
i won't hear anybody else speaking
against the amendment
i will only hear from people who are
interested in speaking four thank you
good counting anyone in support of the
amendment
councillor kit thank you thank you mr
chairman
councillor sober used the word brave
like making a decision like this is not
an act of bravery
i believe the timing of this
is rather hurried and rushed
to have everything in place within a
month
the time frame is far too short
what i would like to see happen is
that a group of people gathered here
today the nominated people
that there should be a a number of
meetings
with the mayor and i say meetings rather
than workshops or maybe some workshops
and to work out how it can work
and how we can make it work together so
that's why i would like it delayed for
the incoming council
in 2022
and i congratulate councillor clark
on putting it forward and that's why i
seconded it so we could have a
discussion about his
his ideas thank you thank you councillor
speaking in support of the motion
creates a reset
those of you that are following the rule
book we can have three speakers one way
and three speakers the other so i would
like to put the motion
i'll see okay
so the motion is uh
that this paper be left on the table
without any decisions
for the upcoming council in october 2022
to consider and act upon that's the
amendment
can i call for a division on this you
can thank you
after we've voted so all those
that support the amendment that's the
kicking for touch
for one for better term if you could
raise your right hand and say i
good eye all those who vote against
the amendment i
so division is yourself councillor
arnold and councillor kent voted
in support was there anybody who didn't
vote
no so the amendment is therefore lost so
we go back to the original
uh recommendations those are the
revised ones that set up there
and now we can start debate on that
is there anybody who councillor
pottinger
look um our role as councillors is to
give effect
to the local government act and
section 81 in our documents here
clearly states what we must do
and the key thing here is decision
making in the states establish and
maintain
processes to provide opportunities for
maori
to contribute to the decision-making
processes
of the local authority and then consider
ways in which it may foster the
development
of married capacity to contribute to the
decision-making processes
of the local authority now our two
standing committees
provide this opportunity because they
have
delegated authority and we are quite
unique in new zealand
of having these two committees and i
think
that giving effect to this we are doing
our job
and i fully support the six
recommendations
thank you just a point of clarification
of clarification
michael the establishment of
of the uh the new roles
doesn't preclude our obligation to
consult
with the wider mighty community when
there are items of significance that
come up
correct
councillors is there anyone just one
just one quick question here
yes through you mr chair um i notice
under the um
the local government act there is no
provision to have appointees on a full
council
how does it and i notice that you do say
it doesn't matter
but we have committees of full council
so is this a
setting a precedent in law or no so
these committees are committees set up
as committees under full council so
the resolution today is still going
through full council
uh so it is not it's quite entirely no
but i'm talking about the appointees
yeah so the employees coming into the
committees are being appointed to the
committee
and we make decisions for full council
at committee level that has been
delegated to this committee so this
committee is a separate structure
to full council so for council can't
have appointed roles a committee can
it doesn't matter whether the committee
is a committee of
everybody on council or whether a
committee is a committee
like a former structure where there may
have been four or five
councillors on that committee so this
committee is a delegated creature of
full council so by way of explanation
then
it would be possible that the next
council could change those delegations
yes thank you just so i can get it right
mr chair
in the past previous councils have had
three and sometimes four committees
so how would that
make the point appointees to a full
committee of council if you don't have a
full committee of council
what would happen then so mr morris the
question is what if we went back to full
committees
so if we went back to the full
committees essentially the roles can
continue on those four committees
this the decisions are still made in
those committees that then go up to full
council for voting on in the same manner
um i can't tell you exactly how that
would work now
because that will actually be a decision
for council in
november 2022 after the elections but
the principles that are in this paper
will carry through there is no reason
for it to be any different
it would just mean that there would be
smaller committees again
so and again sorry mr chair it just it
depends on also what delegations full
council gives those
committees if the delegations are
similar to the delegations to these
current committees i.e the ability to
make decisions
then those voting rights will be
very powerful if the decision is to not
have delegations
uh that do we go back to the old
structure where everything went through
to full council for decisions
uh then those voting rights are
diminished but they're not completely
irrelevant because the committee is
still recommending truthful council to
do something
and that information the manafena
reviews the wider maori views are
incorporated into those decisions
as recommendations to council
councillor amundsen
thanks uh councillor ludlow i fully
support
these recommendations and i fully
support them
for a number of reasons i think the
process that we went through
with engaging with the roonaka
during the consultation or the
questioning around the maori ward was
thorough i think it's really important
to note
that uh even though the question was
about having a maori ward
a lot of discussion did happen about the
pros and cons of that
and what are other options and so
manufenua's seats were talked about
quite often and the
the really strong impression that i got
from everybody
was that actually we just need to do
better
when it comes to engaging with maori and
having maori decision making as part of
our process
and so i think that's really important
to note sorry i've written all over my
page and all sorts of different
angles i think uh
there was the points raised um by
councillor clark
around um the wider naitatu conversation
um and the the leadership i guess of
naitahu but i think for us as people
in invicago and bluff our question needs
to be asked to the
roonaka that are here and the strong
message from them
was that they want to be part of this
they want to be part of this decision
making and that really is our should be
our priority
um there might be changes coming with um
various government changes in the future
we're under a local government review
um uh there's the hefpurapur report
that's been talked about
uh and i think yep those things might
happen in the future or
and some of them hopefully should happen
in the future but actually we need to do
something now
we've had this obligation in the local
government act
since the local government act started
in 2002
this council hasn't you know put enough
effort
into addressing that obligation and
doing something about that obligation
and i don't think that saying that some
things might change in the next couple
of years or the next 10 years or
20 years is a good enough reason to not
act
now
there was also um some discussion or
some mention
about other opportunities that runanga
might have
not taken up with the mural forum i
think it needs to be
born in mind that the merrell form forum
is not a decision-making group
it's uh it's actually just an
opportunity to try and keep that
regional
approach happening um and i think it's
uh you know this is
quite a different opportunity or a place
for maori to be represented on our
council
i do think that we need to make sure
that as part of this process that we
bear in mind
that engaging with wada maori including
mata waka
has to be part of our engagement
processes every single time
in the same way that we should be
engaging with people from the disabled
community
in the multicultural community in all of
those communities young people
elderly people and everything in between
you know we have an obligation to talk
to
literally everyone about the things that
we are wanting to do as part of this
council
and so i think that we've made some
really good
progress over the last wee while of
doing better at engaging and i'm looking
forward to seeing how we
continue to improve that over the next
uh coming years
and i and i know that that's what's
going to be happening here
so i have full confidence that that is
going to help i guess address or
alleviate those kind of issues
and i think ultimately for me the reason
for voting in favor of all these
recommendations
is actually not because it's my decision
but this is the decision for the lunaca
and the roonaka have said this is what
they want
and so i am voting in favor because this
is what they want
thank you councillor sopa thank you mr
chair i'm not going to repeat what i
said earlier in the discussion on the
amendment because i think it is
very obvious that i support the
motions on the floor but i am going to
add something
about the local government act and our
obligations
and i do think that people need to be
reminded that
clause 31 3 of the local government act
actually says that members of a
committee or subcommittee may but need
not
be elected members of the local
authority
the local authority has the ability to
appoint
persons that have the skills attributes
or knowledge
that will assist the work of the
committee or subcommittee
i just want to reflect on the fact that
an import in suggesting the appointment
of the manafenua
appointees who will be chosen by the
roonaka
we are fulfilling the obligation
of having on our committee people with
the skills
attributes or knowledge in a very
important era area for this council
and for new zealand as a whole
that will assist the work of our
committees
and for me that is another very sound
reason
why these why these recommendations
should be passed today
thank you councillor crackit oh thank
you
councillor ludlow um quite a bit of what
i wanted to say
has already been said but i will make a
couple of points
that have been um we are governed by
legislation
and it's not up for colonial new zealand
um i'm a delightful blend of both white
white presenting maori
and new zealand european and as a
delightful blend this is
actually unlike my colleague councillor
abbott one of the easiest decisions i've
ever had to make
partnership is equal relationships need
to be equal
and to be given the money that they
deserve the status quo or opting for the
status quo or to even leave this on the
table
acknowledges neither of those nor does
it acknowledge our previously stated
legislative requirements
the point has been made that um we if we
appoint these
um seats that it doesn't shirk our
obligation to the other 60 percent of
southland ewe that aren't
manufinua and omatawaka
i know this council will probably get
sick of me saying this but
whenever i make any decisions for me it
is about making more capa decisions
and the decisions are not for myself or
for ourselves but for the next
generation of invercargill
so i think that with that in mind i'll
absolutely resoundingly
100 percent be voting for establishing
these seats on our council
thank you councillor rabbit no i don't
know
that's all right it's uh just i'm going
around the table now on on the
substantive motion because
we hear from you councillor clark yeah
thank you jim um
just a couple of things um and comment
to
um the previous
in response to alex's comments about
partnership being equal
um giving manafenoua two seats on a
committee of
15 people is not equality
and some would argue it's tokenism so
i'm not opposed to rangatiratanga
i see that as a way forward but ewe will
reflect and i've heard this many times
that they've had appointments and
consultation positions on many many
council
committees both government and and and
other
committees as well and those committees
have delivered little or nothing
while our progress to the well-being of
ewe
i've spent most of my life in trying to
find ways to enhance the well-being of
maori families and different roles i've
had so uh
i'm still opposed to that thank you
thank you councillor scout
thank you to you chair um thank you
michael for the where's always
comprehensive report and also to knobby
um for your thought-provoking paper
um gave us a bit of objectivity around
the whole
process look um to me it's it's quite
simple um it's simply the right thing to
do
we don't have to be brave we don't have
to be it's just the right thing to do
and it is time it's the right thing to
do michael just
a couple of points for me in the sense
of your paper
um renaka have indicated they are
interested in exploring
that's a little bit open for me they are
interested in exploring so
my only nervousness around that point
is have we completely fulfilled our as a
council
our consultation obligations with the
roonaka to make sure
that we've got exactly what they do want
because
we'd be very grave and um from our
perspective we haven't explored that
completely and i know from your own
words
you did mention um around that
consultation so that would be my own
only to make sure that we have a
complete picture
exactly what they are acquiring or
asking for
um because we can't afford to make a
mistake it's that
the time is right michael certainly i'm
very comfortable that we are
representing um
what one of you know have told us
uh and i believe anyone who was present
at the
long-term plan engagement with
manufacturing
will have heard that message
loud and clear thank you you're right
there's just somebody on the grass you
know
you worship do you want a chance to
speak on the substantive motion
uh just um it's i must say i'm
impressed that we've got such a
liberal-minded counsel
and it's surprising and heartening to
see that we're prepared to
face change thank you sir councillor kit
um on the substantive motion you only
asked a question so if
there's an opportunity for you to speak
if you wish uh could i ask another
question please certainly
uh michael um
these two appointees
do they have to be maori the appointees
from this group
or can they be from some other race
uh the manafinoa and the runakha can
nominate whoever they
feel would be the most appropriate
person so therefore we
could have an irishman and a dutchman if
money finally believed that they were
the most appropriate people to represent
them on these committees
yes i believe without achieving what
they are representing
that is what this is these roles are
intended to do
thank you councillor lush yeah um
through you the chair um
i'm very nervous about coming to the
meeting today um about this discussion
the way it was going to go but
incredibly heartened by the
well thought out comments of people
towards this
um like your worship i was staggered by
matariki at the
queen's park i thought gee this is going
to be interesting sensational
with so much involvement for me when so
much involvement for the community
i wasn't expecting arch but people were
loving it and maybe not so much me
because it's lights and trees but the
children were in
awe of it and you know i just think this
is
it's exciting for me as a new council to
be involved with something that seems to
be so
um such a positive thing to do under the
local government act under the treaty
and for the community um
look i think that's um
it's good for invercargill to get good
news stories around things like this
there have been stories to do with
race have come out of indica would have
gone nationwide that have put us
in a bad light in some ways hopefully
this is a
a uh story that will will go positively
around the country there's been certain
councils that have struggled with this
and um
it has not gone well for the reputation
of those cities i think with challenges
that new zealand has and the world has
with climate change and the environment
and tourism
uh to have this representation is
incredibly valid i also think too as we
look towards the establishment of a
museum
um 50 million 60 million dollars and i
think too when we look at the stories
that we have to tell
in bluff and invercargill that so many
of those involve
naitahu and i think that to have the
involvement
of representatives of the ewe on the
committee is a great thing so i think
i'll certainly vote in favor of this i
think it's a
really really positive thing and yeah
i'm like you worship i'm heartened by
uh the opinions and the sense of process
as well the council's come up with this
um this proposal and yeah hopefully
it'll pass
too so thank you thank you as the mover
of the motion i'll
have the final word um i'm really
heartened to see that we have grown to a
point where we want to
continue to grow what we're
looking to do is to seek to give voice
and to get
understanding um
and understanding from manafenua of of
what it is that they want you can have
somebody who's got maori lineage and
there are a couple of us who sit at the
table but we're not the appointed voices
not even close
but i come from a generation where um
sadly our engagement with maori culture
was
some flex weaving poi stick songs
real 1970s
shame it goes beyond that
i then went through a really interesting
period of learning when i was
taking a unit around tatiati when i was
working for the southern institute of
technology and i watched the
the reactions of of some of the students
to
just having to learn about the treaty
and
and there was in some instances
resistance
and and i understand that because
resistance comes from a place of fear
or just just a lack of understanding um
and and i would talk to the student and
help tell them that i didn't care about
their politics
i simply wanted to teach them a timeline
so that they understood what led to the
signing of the treaty why there are two
different versions and why there is
disagreement
often with i think one exception across
five years
um the response from those who were
reluctant
was astounding i had no idea
was the most frequent reaction
so let's have an idea and it sounds like
you know we are a council that is that
is ready to start to listen we talk
about a a treaty partnership
but
for a true partnership you'd actually
need more seats
an equal number but here's the start and
here's the now
there may be change coming the one
constant that we know will happen
in local government is that there's
going to be change it's going to be
change around the local government
there's going to be change around the
rma there's going to be change around
three waters
there's going to be change around the
way that we want to integrate and
understand what it is
the people of uh
manafino or locally want
so it's with a bit of pride
that i will um put the motion
all those in favor please say aye aye
against would you like your vote
recorded counselor clan thank you
thank you any other votes against to be
recorded
if not thank you councillors and thank
you for the manner in which you've
engaged
speaking of engagement that brings us to
the uh the representation
review and my thanks to the members of
the representation review committee who
have been along here through this
afternoon i noticed one has
had to pop away already um but
michael do you want to take us through
that paper
aditi had to run thank you thank you mr
chair i was trying to work out who had
escaped um well she i don't know she
hasn't got out of the building but
something it was as i'm sure you're all
aware every six years we have the joyful
task of undertaking a representation
review uh
it is our turn for next early the
elections next year
um and so we have been undertaking
up-to-date our pre-engagement with our
community panel which uh mr chair has
already
commented on so at this stage i will um
publicly
acknowledge the community panel uh
chaired by councillor munzen
uh and made up of aditi raj anna ford
david pottinger michael skerritt and
evelyn cook
i wish to thank them all for the very
hard work and their comprehensive report
they have provided
and as part of my presentation um i am
aware that some of the community panel
wish to speak to you
uh so i would like if you leave mr chair
to invite them to do so now
absolutely
evelyn welcome along and thank you for
your mahi through this project
not so much that i wish to speak to you
necessarily but
that i was here to support the report
and answer any questions that may come
out of that
regarding manufa no input
and consultation with matawaka
thank you are there any questions around
those two issues
what's your level of comfort
with the discussions yes
depends on the question um i'm i'm
fairly open to
um i think the uh process that we
undertook was robust
the discussions that we had with amongst
ourselves was likewise robust
and i'm more than happy to support
the reporters it's presented to you and
to defend anything that
may be asked particularly pertaining to
my
input but the the
way that the report speaks about
the matters that were before us
thank you evelyn david welcome
councillor ludlow your honor
fellow councillors bro
uh i'm here to talk about what wasn't
said in the report
because uh in the last wee while
discussing with people
about the actions of the council has
been an interesting experience
and um while we made recommendations in
the report
which are you you will have seen about
the numbers of councillors the
the um committees and the
awards and all that there was a great
deal of other information that was made
clear to me
when i went to talk about you people
and it was made i had people ringing me
up at home they had seen my name
on a list and i'm still possession of a
landline so available in the phone book
and it's those those issues i might if
i can there are three issues one is
knowledge
many of the people in invercargill do
not know
what the council does you get confused
with the ilt
and therefore come in for a bit of abuse
you um they don't understand and hence
the comment i think in the report
about rates what are rates what do they
do who do they set
what happens all my rates have gone up
in the area that i live
next to kennington some of them were
quite upset
uh there's a whole lot of issues there
so that's number one they don't know
what you do
number two 25 percent
of the available people voted most of
them voted for
council allah might point out not for me
i am a i am however a great supporter of
the council i mean i
i tried to join you so i can't say any
other thing other anything else
but 25 and in 2019 it was just over 50
percent
that is a worry people are not voting
it's not just
an invercargill it's a national trend
but
local bodies are not getting the support
you sit here and you make decisions for
the entire city
having only been put here by half of it
or in
marcus's case one quarter of it
and thirdly was diversity
and this was an issue that we came
across
and there are lots of we've talked about
diversity is honor talked about
diversity in the people and the
the different groups that make up
invercargill and i look round the
council
and somebody described and i do not do
not take this personally anybody here
but somebody described me as you lot as
being
male pale and stale
and i defended that because i too
fed into that category and i wish to
stand but this
is an issue it's not part of our review
our review says we like 12 of you
our review says we like being
councillors at large that all of you
represent invercargill city
and as far as community boards go we
spare a thought for the people of
odatara i work with a number of them and
they were
they had their issues but you'll see
that in the report
but it's the other three things people
don't know what you do
people don't want to be part of the
process
and people don't see that you fully
represent them because of who you are
now they they don't know you as well as
i do i know many of you and
you're thoroughly good people but the
i see that the council has
an issue in front of it it's got stones
in its shoe
it's got um issues it's
facing under the changing environment
which we've just heard about
but also we you've got the need the
council's got the need
to be seen as relevant and
part of the changes that invercargill is
going through because nobody's yet
talked about
uh ty in the fix that's going to have
down the track
and um the fact that the very boom is
slowing and there's a whole lot of other
issues there that are going to affect
invercargill
and um i think the future of the council
lies in council's hands and maybe at
some stage
if you go after this meeting and it's
been a very momentous meeting i might
point
out but you need to think about how
we can address some of these issues
and some of this so that people of
invercargill
can be assured that you're sitting here
making the best decisions
for them in the now and in the future
thank you
thanks david councillor emerson you have
been a councillor representative and
chaired this process for the second time
so no stranger to it can i hand to you
sure thank you uh yes
i would just like to uh extend my thanks
to the community panel as well they've
been amazing to work with
uh and there has been a lots of robust
discussion about the different areas
uh which we are supposed to address as
part of the representation review which
is the at large versus ward system
the number of councillors and the
community board
and i think it's fair to say that the um
the otata
community board discussion or potential
for one was
probably the most uh debated
issue that we had alongside the
suggestion of reducing the number of
councillors
so it did take a wee bit of discussion
to
to come to a conclusion there but uh as
you'll see from our
uh report uh we did come to a conclusion
and i guess just to follow on from what
david was saying around
the issues that he found um they were
certainly echoed by a lot of people in
the community
so i'm really pleased to see that there
is a recommendation here that
asks the chief executive to look at
options for addressing some of those
things
or hopefully all of them actually
because i think
they'll go a long way to um helping
raise
uh i guess uh awareness about council
you know and i find too you know people
make all sorts of assumptions about
councillors and council uh you know
people expect that i have an office here
in this building and i'm like no
they're like oh but don't you work there
and it's like no
uh you know and and all of those kinds
of things all of those little things
that people
sort of don't realize alongside the big
things and i think uh
you know one of the things that was
raised was that somebody
was working with somebody who was buying
a house and they didn't even know what
rates were
uh you know so things like that i think
are you know a significant
issues for councils not just ours but i
think councils across the country
to try and work out how do we get people
to have a better understanding about
what council does and and why it does it
and by association the value that they
need to place
on getting involved in voting at one
level
but i think engaging in the different uh
sort of engagement processes
on another level as well so yes so i'm
am i allowed to move was leading to that
yes well
with that i would really like to uh move
these recommendations thank you
thank you thank you um and just to prove
that i did read your report
i noticed that stv is one of those
things you're wanting to get back up
onto the table for discussion as well
can i ask david and evelyn how that
discussion went because we know how it
went
at our table but um we were a bit
puzzled as to why
you didn't adopt it most of us thought
that
stv or some form of
alternative weighted represent
voting process would result in
a more varied
look around the council given that many
people who vote under that system for
example mnp
has proved that people actually will
vote quite strategically
that if that was available a form of
mixed voting would result in a possibly
quite different looking council
in the future and whether that was the
reason that people were scared of it
but however we we do think it should be
given a much more thoughtful
less
this time pressured consideration
that people educate themselves on what
that might mean
in terms of what future councils may
look like
thank you david evelyn just hit on the
education people didn't know what his tv
was
it was not part of our brief and i
talked to a number of people about it
and explained it to them but they did
not know
they do not know the options
um you know my wife is a teacher and she
teaches social studies and
the whole nature of this local body
governance process
is not fully understood and if you do
not learn about it in school
then you learn about it in life or
various other places that some of you
might frequent
that and you get the wrong idea so
people had enough dealing with the
concept that
if there are only eight of you around
this table
why wouldn't it cost less
right i said it would cost the same well
why not have more
or as many people sincerely put it
get rid of the whole
lot of them it was but the comments that
was reflected in the report
yeah the report reflected the polite
version of the comments
because um it came at an interesting
time mr chair
because there was a great deal in the
media
about you people and people confused
what you're trying to do and uh
i think education indication about stv
for education about
how the lack of government role works
the understanding
that there's a lot of work to be done
here
and that way maybe we could reverse the
slowing trend of um
what's happening thank you
councillor pottinger look i just wanted
to comment on the stb
um uh topic because
working with the three waters thing i've
i've i've been a lot in contact with a
lot of
uh senior counselors throughout south
island and one thing we have touched on
was stb and they were amazed that we
weren't stb
and they they they generously gave
their opinion on why
on why it works so well and it was an
eye opener to me too and i think the
education i think this council
should be fully educated on its on the
way it works
and it should be considered
council ashoka thank you mr chair um as
one of those who supported stv as an
option i totally agree with that
um i also just for the panel's
information because you may not have
realized it but we have as a council
given our delegates to the local
government conference
the ability to vote in favour of civics
education
now that's a nationwide issue and it may
or may not carry through the conference
but there is i certainly believe there
is
more that we could do even locally in
the way of
education workshops um the sort of thing
that
the second part of the recommendation
suggests that
the ceo comes back with some
recommendations on
so i think there is a great deal more we
can do but just to reassure you as panel
members
that we have as a council supported
further education as a formal part of
the school system which
which will help with the future
generation um my step grandchildren
counselor crickets child child
and hopefully will educate some of the
parents of those who will
get that education but there are
certainly more i believe we can do
to increase that knowledge and to
increase
people's belief that there is a reason
to vote
in local government elections
councillor clark just one reflection on
what on what evelyn
commented on about stv if you look at
the recent
results in in the last election in
dunedin and wellington you see some
significant changes
certainly in the wellington landscape
gone away from the uh
male parent style um to a majority or
female
significant amount of um marion pacifica
representation and the age is probably
hard so it's a significant impact in
willington and that's
partly due to a different voting system
and
insane for dunedin as well thank you
councillor through youtube dave i can't
really get away with a couple of
comments you see we've got the media
behind me so i'm gonna have a crack
um no i'm not really but knowing what we
do
i've just looked back in the sense of
what our team have done from a comms
perspective
and the last ltp and the communication
that goes out in my opinion
and i'm defending the team here and my
opinion it's been outstanding
the ltp and the communication the amount
of material that went out
right through every piece of social
media every piece of streaming that we
did
was phenomenal and i compare that with
many other councils so
i can't get away with that also
i have concerns when folk come in and
say many
people it's a very small
small side sweep that you've taken the
group have taken of people in our
community
when you get when feedback like that
comes what i'm more concerned about
when we're more interested on a positive
note uh
is that our young people's voice could
you give us a bit of a very quick
reflection on
where that was in in the consultation
because that would be really worthwhile
i think it would be fair to say that i'm
at the more mature end of the spectrum
and that um i probably speak to people
who
are more um
politically aware perhaps then
and and actively involved politically
in ewe politics or or matawaka politics
then
then is the normal run of people because
i meet them at tangi and i meet the
midway and
i meet them on the mirai on the street
sometimes occasionally in a coffee house
but
um young people
are as varied as we are in the terms of
their engagement so the young people
that i know are also very politically
ewe politics engaged so their opinion
tends to be
um more of the
reflective of the fact that they are
more knowledgeable they perhaps are
a little bit educated um
you know most of a couple of our young
ones were sitting behind us before
they've they're they've got degrees or
varying interests
um in terms of their work life that
brings them
into context so i take your point that
the people
with whom we consulted cannot ever be
fully representative but then
nothing that you do is ever fully
representative
but i would say that the young people
with whom i engaged in this matter
were about time what's taken you so long
you know we're glad we're not going to
have to wait until we're as old as you
um i think that might have been my son
but you know that that
this has taken us 181 years
the conversation that we're having now
that that you had earlier
that's taken 181 years that is
not really a rush to the finish line um
so can i just sort of say that whatever
we got from the people with whom we
spoke
was coloured by who we are and who we
know
and where we could access people because
we didn't have the luxury of the public
meetings
although i think david sacrificed
himself and went to more than me
um but you know we we can only reflect
just as you can the people with whom you
converse and
um and the people who volunteer their
opinions upon you
thank you thank you um
yeah you're right when i say many i mean
but i use statistics
lies damn lies and statistics 25
voted in the by-election that's how i
mean many
75 and the people i spoke to
weren't weren't politically motivated
they were the
apprentices and the junior operators
that i worked the people who were trying
to buy a house
the people who are trying to get their
life together
the guy who's had more rouse than with
his partner than he cares to
care about and i asked about the council
and i asked about the roles and asked
about those
um their need is for the
the basic knowledge i i'm just worried
nigel that the um
the the public of invercargill the
community of invercargill
needs to see what's happening here
what they're seeing in the papers all
the the thompson's report and all that
other stuff that was out there in the
playing field
when we were doing this they need to see
this is all relevant
as it is important to the city
and that's why i did what what you're
doing
evelyn with the green bay they said keep
12 people keep it the way it is
just maybe different people
maybe understand what's going on
that's all it's it's it's not
it's not difficult it's not change let's
not throw the baby out with the bath
water
so let's let's work with that and when i
say many well
that's i guess i'm just using figures
that i've gone through and
researched i mean the um
51 of invercargill is
female the voting population
we know that there's uh eighty-five
percent uh
pakiha 17
the numbers don't add up because some
people are multicultural
but we need to be addressing this these
issues because those are the ones that
were raised with us
but they weren't part of our
representation review
thank you councillor clark just one one
quick quick bit of good news
based on what nigel and david are both
said the range for participation in
local body elections ranges across the
country from 35 percent to 60.
and i can tell you we're 60.
um yeah excluding the by-election
oh forgetting the by-election yeah
marcus mark has put away too many votes
here
yeah right we do well
yes we do better than the rest of new
zealand but
even on the basis of that the number
isn't growing
and as you say uh you know it's it's
through a lack of understanding
uh the one thing you know is that people
don't care about the council until their
car disappears into a pothole
which i think was the last time i put
through a request for service
somebody's going to collect the rubbish
when you're flush
everything goes apart from that every
quarter when you pay your rates you'll
have a grumble
um but for those of us that work within
it
we understand it's it's a great deal
more but we certainly thank you for
your mahi over the weeks it's been moved
by councillor
amundsen and uh was seconded by
councillor cracker
i'll put the motion all in favor
thank you
it's all the good source today which
brings us to the active communities
funding
rhiannon and uh also welcome along
brandon mcdermott from sports south and
you want to come and have a
seat up there brenda
sorry from active southland that's my
bad
let's be kind
thanks rana this this follows a lead
that that came from council a while ago
so
we're now at the mechanics point i guess
one way of summing it up
thank you check your counsellors so um
yes you'll recall that this was raised
during the review of funding that took
place
in august last year so since then we've
been engaging with
now active southland as well as sport
new zealand
around the options around this and so
this paper presents those
options to you for your consideration
our recommendation is the act of
southland
is best placed to really drive improved
community outcomes
from the funding and
that the the most efficient manner to
enable that to happen
is to wind up the trust and pass the
funding across
to active south and for administration
going forward
um and so yeah happy to take any
questions
i guess by way of comment i was on
council back when
we were getting funding from the then
hillary commission
to disseminate and the amount of money
that people were drawing on was far
lighter than the amount of money
that we were getting and so this fund
accumulated and i don't think it was
ever the intention of
council that the fund should accumulate
to the point where it becomes
self-seeding i also noted that
through lockdown last year as a lot of
sporting organizations
uh struggled to survive
uh that there was a fund administered by
the then
sport southland now active southland um
brendan could you explain how
going through that process uh
impacted on on what it is you do bearing
in mind that normally you are on the
end of applying for funding kilo
councillors
yes i i guess from a funding perspective
then sport southland has been
distributing funds through kiwisports
for the last
kiwisport funding for the last 10 years
so around about 2 million
over the last 10 years and then through
sport new zealand and money that come
through the government with the
opportunity to distribute money through
the
community resilience fund to and
recreation
organizations last year to enable them
to help them through that short any
shortfall they may have
through um through the post covered
time so um there was two funds
uh i think the first one were restricted
to about 350 odd thousand dollars which
we distributed
uh to regional sports organizations and
clubs and then secondly
uh a second fund which we oversubscribed
and then support new zealand gave us
extra money because of the
subscription uh and it was about the
650. so we had about a million dollars
we distributed out to around about 200
different organizations to support them
uh post covert uh to keep them running
and to my knowledge i don't think we've
had any clubs fall to organizations fold
post covered in terms of sporting and
recreation
organizations which is great councillor
soper
your name appears on on some of the
documentation as a member of the trust
what's your level of comfort with what's
proposed
thank you mr chair um i'm actually very
happy to move these recommendations
um it's been my view for a while that
it's really been a historic accident
that this council and other councils
ever ended up with the hillary's
commission money in the first
place and because we did
a set of criteria were drawn up
those criteria are now somewhat
dated some parts of them are very good
some parts of the very dated
we have as a an active communities
committee as a subcommittee of the trust
made some adjustment to those criteria
but
they would need quite a bit of further
adjustment if we were to
not pass these recommendations today it
seems to me that with
a places and spaces strategy in place
all the discussion that has gone into
that
the the role that we know that
um sports south and now active southland
plays
in the community the fact that they are
the
um in my mind the more appropriate
place for this funding to reside
and we can obviously as council give
some some guidelines
as is said in the report
about the use of of the the money that
would be in the spirit of the original
hillary commission
um devolution um but it
certainly seems to me that um
this would be a very good move it is a
reasonably expensive matter
for council to continue to administer
this trust
it's a very unusual trust it's not part
of our core business it wouldn't exist
if the hillary commission hadn't
devolved the funding they did at a
certain historic point
when i wrote to sport new zealand
initially to ask about the fund i would
have to say there was
perhaps some surprise from sport new
zealand that
the fun still existed in this council's
hands
and that it had grown to quite the level
it had it would seem other councils
who had the same historic accident
did not necessarily go down
airpath in quite the same way so it
seems to me
that it is a good
time to put the funding in responsible
active communities hands um
and with an organisation that council
can have a high level of trust as the
appropriate body to administer the
funding
counselor uh look um um is the motion
being moved
uh no it's just sorry is that a
counsellor but just maybe
yeah right well and and secondly then
then
i think it's a fantastic idea i think
there's too much
inconsistency with council doing it the
change of each term has new people
i think it enables a strategic approach
a cohesive approach that it gets
administered like this and i'm all in
favor of let's go for it
thank you uh jeff we turn the heating
off after five o'clock it tends to hurry
us along
um i i think right that's um the
point that councillor sopa made around
conditions i th
as long as it's delivered with the same
intent with which the hillary commission
granted the money in the first instance
sports
southland now active south and has the
networking within the community to to
understand where needs are
are best met nothing to do with
electricity
no councillor scout i just want to echo
your comments councillor sobers and
councillor pottinger's
active south and do an outstanding job
in the wider community
and i was lucky enough to be at the
launch the other day and that
did you speak at it i did speak it
actually but to be fair
more importantly the community reach
that the organization is making is very
significant
and so congratulations brendan to the
team uh
i think even the naming has encompassed
a whole lot more with active
south and so it's the right place again
it's the right thing to do
i believe so well
thank you any further questions or
comments
counselor evanson i'm just trying to
find
um would the expectation be that
uh the same amount of funding is
allocated each year to be distributed
uh so that the principal remains and it
can be a
no forever because it never should have
been and
and i i guess if if
in disseminating the funding act of
south and find projects that are
that are worthy i mean when the money's
gone it's gone
interest rates and it wasn't ever
supposed to be something that generated
revenue from interest right and that was
from
peter miss kim in the denver i think he
was in charge of sport new zealand he
may still well be
right no if i can back that up
counsellor
um that's that's exactly the
position the it's another part of the
historic accident
of the fund evolution and the way
historically
this council decided to deal with the
funding it's
not necessarily the best way
for this funding to deliver active
communities results
in 2021
thank you know the comments if not i'll
put the motion then all in favor aye aye
aye against carried thank you
thank you thank you brendan
rhiannon you get to stay in the hot seat
uh
just really an update on the saving
grace project
because i know that there was an
expectation through the ltp that we
would report back to the july meeting of
ppp
yes so this report is very much um
just to provide an update on where those
conversations are at
i will just note one change that i just
need to make to report this says that we
will bring a report back in august
but um having received information
from the ic2 trust that they're waiting
on some additional information
that will mean we couldn't report back
in august it's actually going to be
september so
just beg patience on that
and we've had some initial conversations
as the report outlines
and they've indicated that they
understand the conditions around the
funding obviously not to be for purchase
of the building
initial conversations are around
refurbishment
and so we'll shape up um
a further report come back to this
committee in september
thank you councillor second that mr
chair
questions or comments counselor clay on
page 71 rihanna um
you've got there written in italics the
council allocate a hundred thousand four
officers to work alongside
and for me that's a little bit
miscellaneous i thought we allocated
a hundred thousand towards a project
with the potential for
two more lots in subsequent years and
that the way that reads it sort of
implies that we're giving a hundred
thousand to officers
for their work to work alongside the
trust just seeking some clarification on
that
counselor having some so um i think
that's probably just one of those things
that
ended up being part of the impression of
the
recommendation when we were uh pinning
it on the move
so what it does mean is that the hundred
thousand dollars is for the saving grace
project uh but first the officers are
going to work alongside just
trust to make sure that that money is
allocated but it was we did only agree
in that ltp
to do the one-off allocation we didn't
agree to do subsequent demonstrations
okay that's fine thank you thank you
further questions or comments
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor
aye against can we note my abstention
i have an interest not a conflict easier
if i just sit off to the side
and that brings us to the activity
report
who wants the the joyous task of
speaking to these magnificent figures
from
the likes of the library i can
mr chair um willingly he steps forward
willingly step forward
um first i might just if i make
counsellors introduce you to trudy hirst
who is the gm for customer environment
this is treaty's
day number two and she'll be taking this
seat from me
in the next meeting which i'm grateful
for um
so i'm happy to take the report as read
and we'll answer any questions that you
might have
so i'm just going to go back to the
library because it was such a
significant jump
was there any ain't a great thing to see
but was there anything they were able to
put that down to
uh to a degree part of the issue will
have been
called this time or in may last year
the library was just popping out of
covert
and so that's why the numbers and the
percentage variation look
quite significant but but what we have
seen
in terms of the library service is
across the board that their programs are
and the range of services they do offer
including the lending of
both books lego dvds and the like
has increased and so we are seeing more
people engage
and also seeing their engagement is
shifting
to more remote terms of access rather
than just coming into the building to
grab a book
they are engaging through other means
too
thank you i also know with venues and
event services report that there was
such a thing as a silent disco
have you not been to one no no that's
where i've got tinnitus
um it was actually oh i'll see
a point about minerva in the update as
well which i note that
councillor crackit shared around two so
that's been good
councillor skelt thank you through
youtube being a white
pale style and now very grumpy
because it's very cold in here um i
wonder if you could help me with some
gibbling
um just a couple of things um the
anderson house trust
and the workshops could we flesh out a
bit more just in the sense of
time frames and how we're rolling with
that project
uh so the second
that um the manager from the venues and
events team richard mccoy
has been working with a subgroup of the
trust
uh that have run through a range of
discussions on both
the potential future use and that is
included bringing in
event and wedding specialists catering
specialists to provide
advice to the trust on on the realities
of operating that venue
in a range of guises and
from richard's work and with the trust
they are now looking at wrapping up
their advice and that should be with
us it is staff it should be with us
within the next month
and then we'll be bringing that back as
advice to
um council once we're clear and once we
know what the trust's views are
and that they've had an input into that
financial shape of report
and just from an operational point of
view steve just the
scaffold we're on time we're on target
with anderson's house in the sense of
when we might be weatherproofing
uh that's stretching my memory about
counsellor
scout in terms of the capital program
it's a question i if i can i will pass
on to erin
and we can come back with a specific
answer on
how that's tracking okay thank you and
just one other thing just three
venues events just the the number of
events coming through all the
shows and things coming through would it
be or was is there any indicator in the
sense of numbers attending
how are we tracking in the sense of um
through the covert
and the after cover numbers going to the
actual events is quite interesting
and i know we can't from a promoter's
point of view
um be too detailed around that for
confidentiality but it'd be interesting
to know just
in a reporting process are we getting
significant numbers to those or are we
is there sorry is there a sign that we
may be trickling off to attendance to
those sort of events when i look at
the range of activity i noticed the
article the other day re-lammers
and just there's a real pressure point
there are numbers so
is there an indicator just or a snapshot
what sort of numbers we are getting
look i think the general indication from
the management team
is that within the civic and scottish
that we are getting
better engagement from the community and
that includes
um tickets but that also reflects
um we're actually getting a different
behavior but from the promoters you know
they are
tending to book book more and and
probably still in a bit of catch-up mode
post-covert
so we it's hard to point a finger to one
thing or another but we do know that
promoters are more active at the moment
and so they are bringing more shows than
we would have normally
got pre-covered richard has noted in the
report too
around the ticketing behaviour and
purchasing behaviour of people as
they are waiting longer and that's
leaving it up to
other factors as well so okay i i can
ask richard to see if he can include
more information than his next report
around that well that was just
interesting and it's in that very point
you made around that risk factor for
promoters and coming and
and obviously numbers a numbers game and
from a ticketing perspective revenue
stream off ticketing for for us from a
council perspective so
it's just interesting to know where the
market's sitting
the youth market's sitting and what is
big what what folk
so what sort of events are now
attracting our people to go to
and whether collectively as a community
we can be even stronger in driving that
and getting more of that type of thing
into the city as a bigger picture type
thing so
but thank you that's that's good
information someone like to move the
reports perceived
councilor rabbit seconded
councillor amundsen there are no further
questions or comments i'll put
sorry just a quick one for steve
um i wasn't clearing what you responded
back to nigel on but
um my understanding was with the
anderson's house we were going to have
two phases one was to
do the earthquake prime work and seal
the building
and then the second phase was to
identify what potential uses there would
be and that might
that might run us into things like
toilets and kitchens and
access ramps and what have you so we i
didn't
quite get what you were saying to him in
relation to are we going down the track
of resolving the earthquake prone stuff
and ceiling building so um
thank you counselor um so the the
capital program
um is on track to be completed and i
think that is on track to be completed
by may of next year and that includes
the strengthening
and weather tightness work concurrently
richard is working with the trust to
determine once that
piece of work is finished what can the
facility be used at initially
and then that will then drive that
ongoing
potential future use yeah and just as a
side question in relation to what uh
council orlando wrote are you counting
them in and out of the library or just
in
that's a very good question uh we've got
counters on the door
yeah very good yeah no that's fine thank
you
i've got a double click on them yeah
yeah of course
councillor partner i'd like to move
we're going to public excluded
i haven't put the motion yet
so i'd like to move that the report is
received
councillor scout councilman i'll put
that all in favor
against carrie there being no further
business
and open i'll move that we go into
public except with councillor
passenger is moving that would go into
public excluded with the exception of mr
grant and mr mckenzie
as the external appointees and relevant
staff for the reasons as
outlined secondary
systems i'll put that all in favor
right this won't take a minute uh
we've got the minutes of the public
excluded session from june 8th
sorry if we stop this